from the time we started doing polls  back in the Great Depression when asked  do you think things will be better  they've always said yes oh I know the  Bernie people came to say that we're  very sorry you're leaving wait before  can I just say this as they're leaving I  want to say I have earned nine million  votes in this election already I I have  1 million more votes and Donald Trump  and I have two and a half million more  votes than Bernie Sanders  Harris here is what I regret what I  regret is they don't want to listen to  anybody else what I what I regret is  they don't want to hear the contrast  between my experience my plans my vision  what I know I can get done and what my  opponent is promising I'll give you one  example he goes around telling young  people he's gonna give them free college  while I wish it were so but you go and  read the fine print which everybody  should do anytime somebody makes a  promise about something being free